this is Jonathan Ferguson the keeper of
firearms and artillery at the Royal
armories Museum in the UK which houses a
collection of thousands of iconic
weapons from throughout history and on
this week's episode Jonathan is back
taking another look at the Weaponry on
offer in Escape From tarkov I'm
regretting not picking up the um the
infamous emotional support
they're doing it to me again
to concentrate because of how everything
this gun is if you want to see more of
Jonathan reacting to escape from
tarkov's guns make sure to subscribe and
check out the previous videos we've made
on the game's extensive Arsenal and if
you'd like to help with the Royal armies
Museum and continue to support
Jonathan's work check out the links in
the description of this video right over
to Jonathan
um so I'm looking at the the blackout
mp43 side-by-side shotgun we have a
couple of bike out shotguns we don't
have this particular model I noticed as
the as the the model rotates on my
screen Not Unusual now just to be able
to see down the barrel and see the
ammunition that's chambered in the gun
has modeled it's always nice in this
case I can actually see that we have a
the crimped end of a standard presumably
Buckshot round and then in the right
hand Barrel a slug they have actually
modeled as a not a tall surprise to
learn the actual ammunition that's then
going to appear in in the gun so we've
reached a pretty high degree of fidelity
now with um video game Firearms which is
very nice
foreign
this might be the first time I've seen
it modeled the lever for breaking the
gun actually flicks to the side as the
barrels are snap shut as the action is
Snapshot which is something that happens
on all all side-by-side shotguns with a
top lever but I don't think I've ever
seen it done before very satisfying
sound as it as it snaps shut now for
those of you wondering why the cartridge
cases or the hulls or the shells don't
go flying out of the gun in that
completely pleasing fashion that we've
become used to with with game shotguns
that's because this specific model of
the mp43 is not an ejector gun if it was
it would have an e in its name and it
this is just the one C which is a
non-ejected gun now in reality well
across the board actually that means
that when you break it open cartridge
cases are extracted and they stick up
proud so you can grab them and pull them
out but they're not thrown out of the
gun that's kind of a preference thing or
depending you know what sort of
discipline of shooting that you're doing
some really nice modeling of the wooden
stock especially on this one we've got
some really good wear on that sort of
sculpted bit of the wet where the butt
stock meets the the action it probably
wouldn't be fooled if you showed me a
picture of this and you know pretended
it was a photograph of a real gun but
there are moments where I have to take a
second look these days so we're getting
there
now this is a I think this is a new one
on me in video game to well technically
it's a new one on meth will stop because
we we haven't got one of these it's it's
too too new it's the Accuracy
International ax and it follows the
Modern Trend for precision rifles it's
chassis rather than a stock it's highly
modular you change not just a cheap
piece but every aspect essentially is
going to be adjustable for you in this
case key mod accessory system on the
front very long rail across the top for
you to fit range of different Optical
sites all of you know the drill by now
the action itself is a an improved
version of the good old-fashioned not
that old-fashioned nearly as old as me
Accuracy International System so yeah
nothing nothing drastic has changed
there from the the days of the l96 A1 in
terms of the user experience would you
find this thing in this setting I don't
know I think that depends very much on
the in-game ecosystem or whatever you
want to call it in terms of arms dealers
and all of that as in the real world if
you have the right contacts me pay
enough money I'm sure you can get
something as Gucci as this
I've just gone and grabbed a second G36
I did I did grab another one it's it's
one I've featured before on this series
and it's uh disappointingly
semi-automatic UK police carbine the
reason I've I've grabbed hold of it
though is that this is the exact
configuration other than the trigger
pack that we're seeing here in other
words something of the traditional HK
hooded front sight and this particular
variant of the flip up two position rear
aperture as well it's absolutely
identical there are several different
configurations of rail available for G36
just so happens we have the exact same
one and it's really very nicely modeled
so bye roll the stock up to match what
I'm seeing there I can literally hold
this thing off to the screen and look at
every point of reference and it's spot
on it's very rare to be able to do that
G36 are really really solid design much
maligned in the last few years in my
view completely unjustified but there we
go
well a bit of a G36 best this time
here's another one and this is the model
that I'm looking at at the moment the k
um k for Kurtz not not carbine in this
case uh Kurt's being German for short
and it is substantially shorter than the
full I think 20 inch barrel original
rifle to the point where you are losing
a bit of Effectiveness from the 556
cartridge but it was intended for
specialist troops so this is exactly as
we see in the game this one's in very
good condition except for this sort of
piggyback Optical site so this is the
the standard thundersburg configuration
as originally introduced to the German
Army all we're seeing that's different
in the game is that the Red Dot sight is
not fitted and if I were to remove that
you would see exactly what we see here
so this although it seems to sit very
very deep on the rail it doesn't sit
that deeply
um it wouldn't be able to because that's
the actual Optical site below so if you
take this off you get exactly the same
faceted kind of roof-like shape and the
iron or in this case polymer backup
sites are exposed you get the
ability to use these very basic pistol
style combat sites molded into the
carrying handle which is what we see
here
this is the mill core M32 grenade
launcher 40 millimeter grenade launcher
it's not I suppose super widely
encountered but there are quite a few
out there as a grenade launcher it does
fire in quite quite the arc that's
that's positive Advantage when you're
trying to lobb in explosives you you
don't necessarily want to fire strength
level anyway this looks to be very well
modeled indeed including what looks to
be all the functionality that you'd
expect in other words being able to open
it up and rotate the drum to different
position even selectively load different
types of ammunition into your drum
having having never fired one but having
seen some footage the it looks looks to
be realistically modeled grenade
launches in games vary pretty wildly in
how closely they model the actual Arc of
a 40 millimeter grenade this looks to be
right the size of the explosion looks to
be right yeah I I would expect no less
to be honest
oh
I suppose that isn't wildly different
from the hilarious Noob Tube of Call of
Duty close range use of grenade launcher
thing where
correctly uh the the round doesn't arm
at that short distance
arms through rotation it's a safety
thing you don't want the thing going off
near you the question is I think I've
seen somebody try to replicate this
jealous and torso or something is what
what would be the damage to the human
body at that close range from this low
velocity but relatively heavy projectile
I'm not going to say whether this is
right or wrong except to say that I
think of it impacted in the backpack
like that it might not just go down dead
immediately I'm already speculating too
much it is essentially a blunt trauma
weapon inside the arming distance
foreign
we have quite an amusing dropping of
four grenade rounds there and the way
they sort of gently roll off into the
distance for some reason this has
tickled me quite a bit I'd assume you
can pick them back up again you
definitely want to dust them off if you
do that now in reality there'd be a
small risk there of damaging something
by dropping them that would negatively
affect their performance not advisable
to reuse dropped rounds of any kind
really unless you're really in a pinch
or in this case you don't want to waste
some quite expensive ammunition
it's a really interesting gameplay there
with impacts on a hard surface from the
grenade and the person nearby is taken
out more so than I think would be the
case in your typical shooter that seems
to work on a blast radius thing this
appears to be modeling fragmentation if
you're within a meter or two meters of
that explode at the edge of that the
visible edge of that fireball
effectively you've still got some sharp
bits of metal cutting through you and
that's modeled so you can take you can
clearly take advantage of that in the
game by deliberately aiming at a hard
surface to get that
um explosion that fragmentation and take
somebody out
I'm regretting not picking up the um the
infamous emotional support
uh they're doing it to me again so as
the title of the the weapon says this is
the pp19 vichyas which is the MP5
version of the uh earlier bizon
submachine gun that's what I'm going to
concentrate because of how I really
think this gun is but you get the idea
so the the complicated helical magazine
of the of the bizon was I think just too
complicated and not reliable enough it
reverted to a straightforward magazine
well straight in straight out with a
paddle release not unlike the MP5 uh so
in terms of capability pretty similar to
the to the MP5 I think it's fair to say
not as refined and then there's this
thing which has been done purely to Vex
mate that's so you've got like a oh I
don't even know what that is it's like a
bakery PSG One stock on it I'm sure
that's a cur that's that's an actual
type of stock that I don't know I don't
know and you've got everything under the
sun attached to it even the magazine the
magazine vertical grip and the lower
hand guard are all different colors that
kind of clash with each other we've got
the top cover missing just for Giggles I
think I mean I suppose as Coast guns go
it's pretty functional there's nothing
that's going to stop this from working
it's just that that butt stock is
intended for precision fire it's not
going to help you at all with this thing
other than to add a bit of weight
probably in fact you know what the more
I think about it the lessons saying this
actually is it just looks horrific
foreign
to be able to selectively manipulate
different controls on these on these
guns there is a purpose to it so we have
jams or stoppages modeled in the game
and we've just seen one occur there and
the ability to press a button to operate
the bolts when you otherwise wouldn't
need to is of course Central for
clearing stop it very few games model
stoppages at all really interrupts the
flow of gameplay but for a sort of tense
tactical quite realistic tutor like this
it makes a lot of sense when the gun
goes click it's Panic time you want to
seek cover and do your do your immediate
actions um and we've cleared the
stoppage
foreign
and let let rip the way it's modeled in
this game I think is is really good
though because yeah okay a trained
soldier probably shouldn't be putting
the gun around the corner and firing it
unsighted but a lot of other users of
firearms will do that because they don't
want to expose themselves to Fire and it
adds to the sense that this is a real
weapon in the game it's not just bullets
coming out of your forehead effectively
which is what your traditional shooter
the gun is just a layer in front of you
and the bullets are emerging from your
forehead something like this you've got
a range of different controls to
manipulate you've got the ability to
lean to go prone and fire firing the
throne to put the gun around cover and
fire and you just get the sense of a
fully realized weapon
foreign
is of course a very old design by modern
standards but in terms of World War II
Legacy firearms that are out there there
are still a lot of these out there and
it's probably I might be going on out on
a limit but probably the most common of
those Legacy Firearms that's still in
use and one of the more effective ones
as well I don't necessarily think you'd
be running it with the drum magazine
got one here if it is
stupendously cool 71 round drum mag
there unlikely to be in
harder to find in in fully functioning
working order harder to look after so I
think you're more likely to encounter
this thing if anyone's trying to use it
seriously today they're going to be
using the uh 32 round box magazine and
we've got another another gun here
fitted with that I haven't tried into
changing the magazines on these by the
way but quite frequently they don't
that's the other issue with these um not
really with the another reason to to run
the Box magazines because the drums are
not interchangeable for the most part
they were fitted to the guns at the
factory and they were issued from
variety with two drums and if you could
find another one and file it to fit
great but otherwise you're stuck with
your two drums and you'd have to go and
hide somewhere and bomb them back up
again which is a time-consuming
operation admittedly you get 71 rounds
out of it which is fantastic but there
are many solid reasons why they moved
away from the drum not Chris system
because with enough practice it's
perfectly doable but the reload is quite
slick and in reality it's a little
awkward you've got to flip down the
magazine catch lever push that forward
and as you can see not quite as slick at
least for me with my lack of training
and this particular gun and mag but you
know if you if you settled your gun and
magazine and you had more practice than
I have
would be easier but this is this is
quite a tight fit now this is probably
not it is indeed not matched to the gun
so that's that's almost certainly the
main reason why that is not coming off
and going on very easily but hey at
least it fits the gun and it would
operate in the gun
okay this is pretty cool this is the
sort of thing I'd expect to see in
tarkov because it's a modern or
modernized take on an old favorite the
rpk 16 which is a sort of product
improved rpk 74 which is the 5.45
millimeter version of the original rpk
now here is the sort of I'll use this
term advisory heavy assault rifle
problematic in a number of ways um
assault rifles increasingly useless
terms to be quite honest with you anyway
and calling it heavier so I regret
saying that immediately but hey
you see what I mean it's heavy barrel
it's got a compensator a big old drum
mag it's got the reinforced receiver of
an rpk anyway and we've got that that
angle side mounted foregrip which is
designed to carry the player's arm clear
of the drum mag which does make some
sense if you need a lot of Firepower at
close range one of these sort of assault
machine guns is probably the slightly
better term is an option it is being
used but it's a nice nice looking gun I
think
um let's see how it performs
probably worth noting we've actually got
a western western
um Optical site fitted here so that's
the the hammer hamr is a Leupold optic
and why not um all the the current
generation of Russian and other AK
family weapons have Picatinny rails so
you can mount if your unit permits
essentially anything you like to them so
why not have that combination that is
incidentally probably the the main
feature of the rpk 16 over previous
variants is a somewhat solid picatinny
rail top cover the weapon is derived or
developed in parallel to the ak-400
slash ak-12 it's the lmg
variant effectively of the ak-12
[Music]
those were more guns from the excellent
tarkov if you'd like to support us here
at the Royal armories Museum
um the best way to do that is to visit
us if you possibly can we've got some
events going on this summer also worth
mentioning I think the journal that I am
associate editor of the rmax journal
that's the Journal of Cody Firearms
Museum who are good friends of ours as
well it has a new issue out it's a
second issue from the revived Run please
do check that out it is paid for but I
like to think it's worth it so otherwise
guys we'll see you again next time
[Music]
thank you
[Music]